i've been thinking a lot about that
especially in um
the human uh robot interaction context
you know i mentioned spot the boston
dynamics robot
there is something about human robot
communication let's say let's put in
another context
something about human and uh
dog contacts like like a living dog
where there's uh there's a there's a
dance of communication first of all the
eyes you both look at the same thing and
you
the dogs communicate with their eyes as
well like if
if the if you and a dog want to uh
like deal with a particular object
you'll look at the person
the dog will look at you and then look
at the object and look back at you all
those kinds of things
but there's also just a elegance of
movement i mean there's the
of course the tail and all those kinds
of mechanisms of communication it all
seems natural
and often joyful and for robots to
communicate that
is it's really difficult how to figure
that out because it's it's almost
seems impossible to hard code in you can
hard code it for a demo purpose with so
you know something like that but it's
essentially choreographed
like if you watch some of the boston
dynamics videos where they're dancing
all of that is choreographed by human
beings
but to learn how to with your movement
demonstrate a naturalness and elegance
that's fascinating of course in the
physical space that's very difficult to
do to learn the kind of
at scale that you're referring to but
the hope is that you could do that in
simulation and then transfer into the
physical space
if you're able to model the robots
efficiently naturally
yeah and and sometimes i think that that
requires a theory of mind
on that yes on the on the side of the
robot that
that they as they understand what you're
doing because they
themselves are doing something similar
and uh that's a big question too
uh we talked about how intelligence in
general
and and the social aspect of of
intelligence and
i think that's what is required that we
humans understand other humans because
we assume that they are similar
to us um we have one simulation we did a
while ago ken stanley
um did that um two robots that were
uh competing um simulation like you said
they were foraging for food to gain
energy and then when they were really
strong they would
bounce into the other robot and win if
they were stronger
and we watched evolution discover more
and more complex behaviors they
first went to the nearest food and then
they started to
plot a trajectory so they get more get
more but then they started to take
pay attention what the other robot was
doing and in the end there was a
behavior where
one of the robots the most sophisticated
one uh
you know sensed where the food pieces
were
and identified that the other robot was
close to uh
two of a very far distance and there was
one more food
near by so it faked
that's now i'm using anthropomorphized
terms but it made a move towards those
other pieces
in order for the other robot to actually
go and get them
because it knew that the other the last
remaining piece of food was close
and the other robot would have to travel
a long way lose its energy
and then uh lose the whole competition
so there was like emergence of something
like a theory of mind
knowing what the other robot would do
guided towards bad behavior in order to
win
so we can get things like that happen uh
in in simulation as well but that's a
complete
natural emergence of a theory of mind
but i feel like if you
add a little bit of a place for a theory
of mind to emerge
like easier then you can go really far
i mean some of these things with
evolution
you know you add a little bit of design
in there
it'll really help and i think i tend to
think that
a very simple theory of mind
will go a really long way for
cooperation between agents
and certainly for a human robot
interaction like it doesn't have to be
super complicated
um i've gotten a chance to in the
autonomous vehicle space to watch
vehicles interact with pedestrians or
pedestrians interacting with vehicles
in general i mean you would think that
there's a very complicated
theory of mind thing going on but i have
a sense it's not well understood yet but
i have a sense it's pretty dumb
like it's pretty simple there's a social
contract
there where between humans a human
driver and a human crossing the road
where um the the human crossing the road
trusts that the human in the car is not
going to murder them
and there's something about again back
to that mortality thing
there's some dance
of ethics and morality that's built in
that you're mapping your own morality
onto the
the person in the car and even if
they're driving
at a speed where you think if they don't
stop they're going to kill you
you trust that if you step in front of
them they're going to hit the brakes
and there's that weird dance that we do
that
i think is a pretty simple model but of
course it's very difficult
to introspect what it is and autonomous
robots in the human robot interaction
context have to
have to build that current robots are
much less than what you're describing
they're
currently just afraid of everything
they're they're more they're not
the kind that fall and discover how to
run
they're more like please don't touch
anything don't hurt anything
stay as far away from humans as possible
treat
humans as ballistic objects that you
can't
uh that you do uh with a large spatial
envelope
make sure you do not collide with that's
how like you mentioned elon
musk thinks about autonomous vehicles i
tend to think
autonomous vehicles need to have a
beautiful dance between human and
machine
where it's not just a collision
avoidance problem but a weird
dance yeah i think that you these
systems need to be
able to predict what will happen what
the other agent is going to do
and then have a structure of
what the goals are and whether those
predictions actually meet the goals and
you
can go probably pretty far with that
relatively simple setup already
but to call it a theory of mind i don't
think you need to i mean it it doesn't
matter whether that pedestrian has a
mind
it's an object and we can predict what
we will do and then we can predict what
the states will be in the future and
whether they are desirable states
stay away from those that are
undesirable and go towards those that
are desirable so
it's a relatively simple functional
approach to that
um where do we really need the theory of
mind
maybe maybe when you start interacting
and
you're trying to get the other agent to
do something and jointly so that you can
jointly
collaboratively achieve something then
then you then it becomes more complex
well i mean even with the pedestrians
you have to have a sense of where their
attention
actual attention in terms of their gaze
is but also like a tent
i mean there's this vision science
people talk about the celtic just
because i'm looking at it doesn't mean
i'm paying attention to it
so figuring out what is the person
looking at what is the sensory
information they've taken in
and the theory of mind piece comes in is
what are they
actually attending to cognitively
and also what are they thinking about
like what is the computation they're
performing
and you have you have probably maybe a
few options
you know for the pedestrian crossing it
doesn't have to be
it's like a variable with a few discrete
states but you have to have a good
estimation which of the states that
brain is in
for the pedestrian case and the same is
for attending with a robot
if you're collaborating to pick up an
object you have to figure out
is the human like uh like there's a few
discrete states that the human could be
and you have to you have to predict that
by observing the human
and that seems like a machine learning
problem to figure out
uh what's how the human is uh what's the
human up to
it's not as simple as sort of planning
just because they move their
arm means the arm will continue moving
in this direction
you have to you have to really have a
model of what they're thinking about and
what's
the motivation behind the moment and
here we are talking about
uh relatively simple physical actions
yeah but you can take that
to higher levels also like to predict
what the people are going to do you need
to know
what uh what their goals are uh what are
they trying to are they exercising are
they just trying to get somewhere
but even even higher level i mean you
are predicting what people will do in
their career what their life themes are
do they want to be famous
rich or do good and that takes a lot
more information
but it allows you to then predict their
their actions what choices they might
make
you